[Musique]
nous n'annonçons pas
à l'horizon se dessinent les crêtes du
mercantour
un massif alpin dont la beauté contraste
désormais avec certaines de ces vallées
défigurer la roya notamment du nom de la
paisible rivière devenu torrent
destructeur lorsque s'est abattue la
tempête alex
[Musique]
je suis philippe tabarot je suis
sénateur des alpes-maritimes et je suis
conseiller régional en charge des
transports
j'ai été élu au céda à la fin du mois de
septembre dernier puis j'ai eu
l'occasion rapidement de rentrer dans le
vif avec la tempête alex et et les
conséquences dramatiques sur trois de
nos vannes et la vallée de la tinée la
vallée de la vésubie et la vallée de la
roya
ça devait être le marché
la catastrophe du week-end
événement
deux sets
des corps détruits
il faut imaginer
c'est quand même
et
une jambe
demain salle
on était pratiquement des premières les
meilleurs sites de
le temps de nous
pour parer à l'urgence philippe tabarot
pousse alors pour la mise en place de ce
pont aérien
financé par la région sud cet
hélicoptère relie nice attendent une
commune quasi coupée du monde privée de
ter est très difficilement accessible
par la route et on avait pris
l'engagement de revient à attendre
près de 1500 personnes qui n'ont
autorisé l abolition sens médical et mes
copains renard on a aussi contribué avec
cette maison à permettre de retrouver
une nuit
elle est normale même si c'est pas tout
à fait normal se déplacer
[Musique]
je n'en ai pas
on avis meilleures conditions plus
qu'une visite de courtoisie philippe
tabarot vient renouveler son engagement
devant les élus c'est ce que j'avais dit
à la mairie à toute son équipe
municipale que tant que le train ne
serait pas rétablie sur la vallée ont
gardé cette cette rotation hélicoptères
ça nous paraissait indispensable quand
je vous ai appelé chaque fois que j'ai
demandé est ce qu'on peut encore
prolongé cette opération immédiatement
on m'avait répondu d'une façon positive
vous avez rencontré le président du
geôlier tous les deux nous avons dire
ici à la population de tende et l'abri
un service que nos bureaux
les élus n'ont qu'une dizaine de minutes
montre en main pour s'entretenir
car l'hélicoptère monte à vide doit
repartir avec trois passagers à son bord
parmi eux ce jour là amélie 27 ans la
jeune femme est enceinte de sept mois et
doit impérativement consulter son
gynécologue à nice
[Musique]
elle reprit n'est libre à moins de deux
mois des marais
[Musique]
pour rejoindre la côte 20 minutes
d'hélicoptère contre 2 heures de voiture
sur des pistes accidentées à deux mois
du terme de sa grossesse
amélie n'avait plus d'autre solution
pour en voiture a ajouté m
[Musique]
si le pont aérien fait du bien à la
population son coût pour la région est
important 190 mille euros depuis la
tempête
c'est trop c'est la question
seront
l'année
n'y avait eu cette solution
[Musique]
en transportant des dizaines de
passagers chaque semaine le pont aérien
continue de prouver son utilité
mais la mesure fait du cas par cas et
reste le signe que l'urgence s'éternise
dans la roya
oui on est tout à fait dans une
situation provisoire il ya des problèmes
de fond qui demeure sur sur les
questions de reconstruction sur les
questions de foncier sur les questions
d'assurance sur les questions de
mobilité qu'il faut régler de manière
pérenne et donc là encore on aura la
beuze le besoin de mobiliser toutes les
forces vives du département de la région
et surtout de notre pays
[Musique]
c'est dans ce décor figé hors du temps
que la roya morceau sa reconstruction
elle s'annonce difficile longue et
coûteuse et pour le moment à deux
vitesses d'un côté les infrastructures
lourdes capte la majorité des
financements la départementale 62 04 et
ses travaux estimé à 450 millions
d'euros ou la ligne ter ni stand au
moins 30 millions
mais derrière ces chantiers jugés
prioritaires des dizaines restent en
suspens chez les habitants obligés de se
tourner vers des bénévoles voler au
secours des sinistrés est devenue
l'obsession de wilfrid bricourt ému par
la catastrophe
ce fonctionnaire de 51 ans a monté une
association des deux sinistrés chaque
week-end il fait quatre heures de route
depuis le vaucluse pour porter
assistance à ceux qu'il nomme les
oubliés de la roya
[Musique]
on a dû créer une association nous qui
n'hésitait pas même voix ce soir et
écrire au mois de décembre
du coup j'ai créé l'association pour
l'histoire rassemble un petit peu ces
fonds de njai ce couplet refrain rouge
et d'autre mais effectivement on en a
pas des deux départements de l'état on
trouve que les personnes sinistrées sont
pas allés en tout cas les personnes
sortir la vie de s'attarder radio
s'attarder sur les grands axes routiers
pour libérer la vallée après l'élan qui
vit autour a eu de se débrouiller
ce jour là près de fontan il vient en
aide à pierre roy ce retraité de 80 ans
à la santé fragile habite avec sa femme
dans un amour très reculées
pour y accéder il faut marcher une heure
sur ce sentier de randonnée escarpé
excusez moi je vais vous doublez chef le
couple d'octogénaires est isolé depuis
des mois faute de chemins carrossables
pour rejoindre le village le plus proche
de piste mais après l'aider à tempête
alex cette piste est restée impraticable
il y avait des ravines de ahmed à 80 cm
de profondeur ce qui fait que ce n'était
plus du tout praticable avec un véhicule
qu'elle déçoit même un 4/4 impraticable
s'il n'y avait pas des gens comme ça je
crois que dans toute la vallée après ça
les gens qui sont retrouvés avec des
maisons empire et pleine de boue en
sable et jusqu'auprès ce que toi j'irai
dire faut dire que ces gens là ont le
vrai terriblement terriblement pour
aider tout ce qui était sinistrée
parce que sinon je veux pas critiquer
mais
parce qu'il ya personne ne restait à ce
que vous faites pour être réaliste et
regarder les choses en face
on va changer en face et de pelles gens
qui travaillent dur mais allez on va les
voir
pour atteindre le chantier il faut
encore montées en quatre 4 7 fois au pas
d'homme
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes prêts à faire un travail en
deux temps un premier temps on passe on
casse avec la brh tous les gros cailloux
qui soit sur les côtés en milieu de
piste et dans un deuxième temps
en irak la piste pour refaire deux
niveaux la piste à chaque minute qui
donne un coupet a truck drh c'est la
piste qui revit et nous également par la
même occasion le chantier modeste 2000
euros environ pour une journée financé
par la croix rouge et le secours
populaire
pourtant wilfried a bataillé pour
obtenir ces seuls financement une
situation qui révèle selon lui certains
dysfonctionnements des pouvoirs publics
dans la reconstruction
le tissu associatif qui s'organisait les
arrange bien les bénévoles font le job
on laisse faire et puis ça va ça va
voilà on fera le bilan après mais ces
quelques bouteilles mois des personnes
encore coincés en une matinée
l'équipe de wilfrid a rendu praticable
500 mètres de piste sur les deux
kilomètres et demi à remettre en état la
foule
non mais c'est bien pékin
en attendant la suite des travaux pierre
qu'on vit chez lui l'ensemble des
bénévoles
[Musique]
donc je disais que tout le monde on
remercie monsieur wilfried et toute son
équipe
malo pour les travaux et votre joie
quand on repart c'est notre vrai qu'on
parle
1000mercis josiane bien côté le pire moi
j'aime bien le bisou bisou
[Musique]
critiqué pour la lenteur de son action
l'état assure pourtant faire preuve de
volontarisme depuis la catastrophe
un fonds d'urgence de 100 millions
d'euros a été créé pour aider les
collectivités et devrait être abondée
prochainement de centaines de millions
supplémentaires
il pourrait même atteindre le milliard
reconstruire emmanuel macron s'y était
engagé reconstruire des infrastructures
que les collectivités seule ne pourrait
pas à reconstruire reconstruire aussi de
manière conforme à l'esprit que nous
portons c'est à dire de manière
résiliente et durable
vous aviez pennetier mais écoutez je
suis le préfet chargé la reconstruction
des vallées sinistrées dans les
alpes-maritimes et donc je suis arrivé
quelques semaines après cette terrible
tempête
président de la république a eu un
message très fort en indiquant que
l'engagement de l'état serait conséquent
et que l'état mettrait tous les moyens
nécessaires pour assurer cette
reconstruction
dans les meilleurs délais donc j'ai été
nommé sur 7 cette feuille de route qui
s'articulait finalement en deux temps
une première étape qui consistait à
gérer les urgences et une deuxième étape
qui consiste en fait à coordonner à
piloter cette reconstruction
moi je vois un peu mon rôle comme un
rôle de chef d'orchestre à la
reconstruction auprès du préfet des
alpes-maritimes pour essayer de faire en
sorte que tous les acteurs jouent de
manière symphonique
trois jours par semaine xavier pelletier
troque son bureau contre ce cap 4 pour
parcourir les vallées
ce jour là il se rend aux confins de la
roya attendent pas de réunion formelle
au programme mais une visite de terrain
en prise directe avec les problèmes
qu'est-ce qui est une méthode xavier
pelletier c'est prétentieux non en tout
cas faire attention aux autres surtout
quand on sait ce qu'ils ont vécu ils ont
vous vécu des moments extrêmement
traumatisant moi je les ai pas vécu mais
j'essaie d'être le plus possible à leur
écoute
ils n'ont pas besoin d'un technocrate
voilà qui vient leur donner des conseils
nous leur donner des instructions
[Musique]
monsieur le maire quand allez-vous vous
allez bien heureux de vous accueillir
merci beaucoup vous allez bien bonjour
monsieur profonde et de suite lyon oui
[Applaudissements]
dans ce village encore à vif ou un quart
de la population a déserté la mission du
préfet est avant tout de rassurer des
habitants persuadés que l'état les a
oubliés maintenant c'est le contrecoup
s'est dit mais qu'est ce qui devient
notre village pionnier mais il faut
[Musique]
encore plus beau demain il y avait une
alimentation aussi là j'ai toujours eu
fermé mais c'est fermé depuis très
longtemps je suis tout à fait convaincu
d'avoir une centrale à béton à breil et
une attendent ça permet de nourrir le
chantier des deux côtés bien sûr guidée
par le maire xavier pelletier tentent de
prendre la juste mesure des chantiers à
mettre en oeuvre comme sur cette piste
accidentée qui relie tendent à castérino
l'un des hameaux rattachés à cette
commune aussi vaste que paris intra
muros
puis-je y voir un champignon
effectivement on me dit la piste est
étroite mais on peut aménager des zones
de croisement on voit bien que c'est
extrêmement difficile de le faire on
voit bien que c'est une piste dangereuse
qui a des abruzzes que une une erreur de
conduite et on bascule dans le ravin à
quoi on a eu des réunions à nice on a eu
toutes les peines toutes les peines à
expliquer que cette route on ne pouvait
pas faire un croisement des véhicules
donc la prochaine réunion qu'on a on
sait qu on perdra plus de temps a prouvé
qu'on ne peut pas circuler là le préfet
l'aura vu de visu et poivrer m'en aller
dans l'autre sens
à chaque déplacement le préfet doit
surtout s'employer à apaiser la colère
des sinistrés excédés
xavier pelletier se rend chez séverine
lanteri au hameau de vielles vola l'un
des plus meurtriers
cette éleveuse vient d'être averti par
son assureur sa maison ne présente pas
de dommages structurels
elle peut se réinstaller en théorie mais
impossible du point de vue de l'état la
bâtisse pourrait être trop exposés en
cas de nouvelles crues pour le préfet
des études complémentaires s'imposent
mais elle risque de prendre encore du
temps
on ne fera pas les choses à la légère
maintenant ils sont en train d'évaluer
combien coûte la protection de la maison
si la protection de la maison des jeunes
si on peut la protéger d'abord protéger
la maison ça coûte plus cher que vous
dites pour une fois je m'en fous qu'on a
acheté la terre on se le fait nous bon
mais non ils vous laisseront pas faire
si le dit gekko la maison s'ils disent
que la maison ne peut pas être protégés
de gérard h et c'est ce qu'il est une
exploitation histoire bien sûr
voilà là mais on vous laissera pas
tomber on ne vous abandonnera pas on a
des fondamentaux mais je n'y comprenais
pas ce que c'est qu'un site maison puis
en vrai on a mis notre sens là dedans
notre fatigue notre mère on a tous fait
nos mains et on nous annonce qu'on batte
ou perles pour une histoire
d'enrochement parce qu on a une rivière
des 15 mètres de large à c'est pas ça le
sujet le sujet c'est que demain c'est un
événement dramatique se reproduisait que
vous ne perdiez pas la vie parce qu'on
vous arrive à percer là je vous dis
franchement moi je dis franchement j'ai
dit à mon mari ce matin quand on m'a
annoncé ça je préfère être dans la
maison ils partirent est la maison parce
que c'est invivable ce qu'on lit c'est
invivable
depuis le mois d'octobre on sait pas
comment vit on va on sait pas ce qu'on
va faire
est-ce qu'on récupère est ce qu'on va
pouvoir continuer et c'est nous qui vous
remet lentement et tony moore
vous voyez bien on touche à ce qu'il ya
de plus intime chez les gens à leur
maison mais on peut pas prendre des
décisions à la légère on peut pas leur
dire on va détruire votre maison où on
va là là préservé on va la protéger
quand on peut pas le faire donc
tous les services sont vraiment
mobilisés pour que l'on puisse trouver
des solutions pérennes résiliente
mais ça nécessite un tout petit peu de
temps beaucoup d'étude pour comprendre
le phénomène
mais voilà donc c'est vrai que c'est
compliqué
[Musique]
définir des priorités arbitres et les
maires des six communes de la roya
placés en état de catastrophe naturelle
ils sont confrontés chaque jour pour
reconstruire leurs administrés n'ont
plus le temps d'attendre
alors je m'appelle ses bastions la rend
chez 27 ans j'ai été élu maire de breil
sur roya
o le 15 mars dernier nous avons été
touchés par la tempête alex qui a
emporté trois vies sur la commune de
breil sur roya et provoqué des dégâts
matériels absolument considérable sur la
seule commune de bras et ce sont trois
ponts qui ont été emportées et des
dégâts qui sont chiffrés à 20 millions
d'euros
pour sébastien olharan l'urgence est de
rétablir les infrastructures vitales et
désenclaver ce qu'ils le sont encore
comme le quartier de veille 2 km au nord
de sa commune
[Musique]
le pont pour y accéder a été détruit par
la tempête voici son remplaçant une
structure métallique de 36 tonnes
[Musique]
c'est la plaie je lui expliquer tout ça
je vous remercie pour ce retour alors là
on est sur un pont communal qui dessert
un quartier dans lequel il ya vingt-cinq
familles donc c'est la mairie qui a
conventionné avec le centre national des
ponts de secours pour obtenir ce pont et
le département nous aident à la fois
financièrement et en terme de logistique
c'est une étape extrêmement importante
et symbolique s'est aussi d'une certaine
manière la première pierre de la
reconstruction de la commune de breil
sur roya
[Musique]
bon c'est vrai que maintenant on va être
désenclavé complètement par rapport à
leur logement à d'autres personnes dans
la vallée qui j'espère eux aussi auront
droit à un joli passage comme ça et
c'est énorme ce qu'ils font c'est on
peut pas moi je remercie donnerai
toujours le maire parce que tu ce qui
fait pour ce village c'est énorme
s'il semble pérenne ce pont reste une
solution provisoire
la commune financièrement fragiles a dû
choisir cette option à 27000 euros
contre 2 millions et demi pour un pont
définitif et c'est un pont qui pourra
rester alors certes il a toutes les
caractéristiques d'un pont d'un pont de
secours mais ça peut aussi être le
symbole de ce qu'on a vécu et d'une
phase par laquelle on passe
nécessairement c'est à dire une phase de
reconstruction
progressive et qui prend du temps
à l'image de sébastien olharan les
maires savent que leur impulsion sera
déterminante pour imaginer la praye
reconstruire ces villages dévastés en
prenant mieux en compte l' aléa
climatique
[Musique]
au fur et à mesure et bien qu'on a des
phénomènes météo de plus en plus
violents et de plus en plus fréquents et
bien chaque fois qu'on reconstruit on
veut construire différemment en étant un
petit peu plus résilient en s'adaptant
aux risques et en mettant en place des
mesures de protection pour autoriser les
personnes à habiter dans ces secteurs
aux côtés des maires les sénateurs
planchent d'ores et déjà sur une
évolution de la législation pour leur
faciliter la tâche
les territoires de montagne comme la
roya sont soumis à une loi spécifique
qui protège la biodiversité et encadre
l'urbanisme les sénateurs entendent
d'assouplir la loi montagne est obsolète
pour les cas précis des des vallées je
crois qu'il faut travailler sur le
foncier également donc la législation
doit absolument évoluer et qui mieux que
les parlementaires pour la faire évoluer
à l'occasion du projet de loi climat ou
de la nouvelle loi sur la
décentralisation les sénateurs projette
de remettre sur la table des mesures
issues de précédents travaux
il souhaite notamment modifier le
principe de reconstruction à l'identique
actuellement la loi montagne impose
qu'une maison touchée par une crue soir
construites de la même manière au même
endroit
or cela est impossible pour certaines
bâtisses touchés par la tempête alex
l'idée du sénat et de rendre
constructible davantage de terrain sur
des communes qui en manque cruellement
[Musique]
ils sont déjà demandé une forme
d'assouplissement de la loi montagne
pour que les habitations qu'on pourra
plus reconstruire en bordure de rivière
on puisse les reconstruire sur de
nouveaux terrains qui pourraient être
ouverts à l'urbanisation et qui
aujourd'hui ne le peuvent pas à cause
d'eux des règles d'urbanisme qui sont
tout de même assez contraignante quand
on est en zone de montagne
je crois qu'il faut pas démonter les
logiques qui sont derrière la loi
montagne il faut peut-être des
souplesses mais déjà il ya eu un certain
nombre de réformes qui ont amené des
assouplissements
moi je pense qu'il faut peut-être dans
lé contexte qu'on connaît dans les
vallées regarder à nouveau et tout ça
mais avec beaucoup de délicatesse
derrière ce travail parlementaire qui
s'amorce l'enjeu est de taille éviter à
tout prix que cette valve est déjà sur
le fil ne se dévitalise la rendre à
nouveau attractive seul moyen pour la
roya d'entrevoir la fin du cauchemar
bon à la sortie de crise et des
commerces qui réouvre la sortie de crise
et des populations qui reviennent dans
la vallée c'est de voir des inscriptions
à l'école que ce soit breillot attendent
ou dans les autres communes
ça va être ça la vraie sortie de crise
c'est la vie qui reprend et si la vie
reprend demain et si ces vallées ne sont
pas abandonnés là avec les élus locaux
on aura gagné la partie
[Musique]
mais
on